[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous allez faire de cinq
chambres vous aurez jamais d'enfants à
temps c'est quoi c'est peut-être là ou
non je ne fais aucune tête tu es juste
mon train de la ferme de bonnes
disputent les amoureux ya plein
d'enfants à adopter
j'ai trouvé une urgence une réunion à
l'ozone au niveau non non non non pas ça
tu voulu démolir je rentre à peine du
boulot on a trouvé une fille qui
pourrait convenir
les gens se sauve en courant si on leur
parle d'adolescents mister gay passent
leur temps à regarder des changes vis
aux jeux vidéo sur que tu as lu juste
pour info on entend tout ce que vous
dites mais pas de soucis allait discuter
avec les petits surtout ne vous en
faites pas pour nous by elle est plutôt
cool
elle a un frère et une soeur qui sont
plus jeunes fans et rita trois gosses
sait trop pourquoi vous nous montrez ça
comment vous voulez qu'on dise non
maintenant faites comme chez vous je ne
dis pas qu'on ait des parents parfaits
tous les sombres acerbe il s'endort mais
je crois qu'on a la fibre par terre
[Musique]
vous êtes sûr
[Rires]
rappelez vous bien que ça ne va pas être
facile maman de gauche arrive c'est du
marqueur temps à part une bonne semaine
ensuite ces enfants vont tester vos
limites j'ai fait au moins 150 parties
de candy land avec l'état vous avez déjà
joué un candidat c'est violent je
confirme il et s'appuieront précisément
là où ça fait mal on aurait dû prendre
un bébé qui n'a pas d'opinion et 10 pas
la poitrine
c'est quoi cette tenue désolé pas
m'habiller en bière un gars comme toi
c'est du vrai qu'à ce milieu d'abord je
m'habille comme une vieille rengaine ne
laisse pas de fausse mort avec un peu de
stabilité d'amour ces enfants vont
s'épanouir suite la réparer regardez
toutes belles
prenez pas trop con j'ai pas trop mois à
temps
[Musique]
m
la paroisse est fait et c'est le fit ou
plus et seuls fidèles même des marty c
est ce qu il s'agit de chaque camp les
photos de buts inscrits
ma chérie c'est quoi exactement à saïfi
de bic au nom d'un chien ça c'est une
belle truite
[Musique]
on a vu la photo de tulle a envoyé
j'accorde la chance que pour être
rectifiées de portraits paul caro
comptable est amer on va te faire la
misère et meaulnes d'alain jacob mais je
m'épile ben jacobs
ok c'est bon vous suis d'accord
[Musique]